[Music]
urinals matter and public urinals matter
especially
but there's one country in the world
that does public journals like no other
and that country is the Netherlands
going back centuries the Dutch have had
an intimate relationship with water
management
and in cities like Amsterdam the Dutch
had to construct specific forms of water
management Hardware to withstand drunk
British males
holding all other variables equal when
presented with an open environment and
the need to urinate certain locations
have a much higher probability of being
chosen
this includes common objects like trees
or alleys
but in the Netherlands there's a unique
object that presents a unique Danger
on a late night in Amsterdam a man finds
the slow gray running water of the
canals a bit too hard to ignore
he walks over disoriented and unstable
and also a bit too confident
he unzips his fly and releases only to
get light-headed and stumble and fall
into the cold Canal below
there's no way back
cold and increasingly aware of what's
happening the noise of other loud
British tourists drown out the sounds of
his drowning
Amsterdam's red light district is a
notorious tourist attractor since
alcohol consumption increases the need
to urinate and self-confidence there
have been multiple piss related
drownings in the Netherlands
piss-related drownings are one of the
most significant causes of drownings
each year with victims easily being
identifiable due to their unzipped flies
alcohol reduces your blood pressure
emptying your bladder quickly reduces it
even more
combine both with unstable footing and a
Wandering drunk tourist has a much
higher risk of falling into a canal
once Fallen they have the added problem
that a canal is not easy to climb out of
and being inebriated reduces motor
function while making you more likely to
swallow dangerous amounts of water
in an attempt to reduce piss-induced
drownings the Dutch have had to come up
with a genius solution this is the plus
curl also known as the piss curl a
phenomenal example of Dutch urban
planning and Design
when looking at this map of Amsterdam
you can see that the plus kill is
strategically built near water and at
places with the largest number of
British tourists the highest
concentration of kills can be found in
the heart of the red light district
and the Cool's design is just as
impressive as its planning
it's shaped in the form of a golden
ratio sheets of affordable long-lasting
cast iron metal are bent into a
beautiful curve
[Music]
there's also an open bottom so that it's
clear to others whether the kill is in
use and it does it without revealing the
self-conscious user
although the exact Secrets behind the
plus kills design are lost in time it's
undeniable that the inventors were
geniuses
the legs of the possible are in the
shape of a bladder
Amsterdam is an international City
attracting people from multiple
different backgrounds and languages
where the bladder legs designed so as to
make it intuitively clear to all that it
was built for urination
we'll never know
the cool is also a lot more welcoming
and clearly superior to the hard angle
public urinal the design should
obviously be soft and welcoming no not
hard and cold the dark green also makes
it blend in naturally within the
cityscape better a urinal that's natural
to use than one that brings large
amounts of attention to you
the designers also made it so that the
plus skill delicately combines both
elements of Municipal and National
branding
on some of the older Metal Frames you
can find Saint Andrews crosses this
serves a try function advertising the
city of Amsterdam ensuring ventilation
and giving a clear-eyed view of the
street to the vulnerable user
zoom out and then you begin to see the
strong National Design Elements
combining both the Dutch tiling
tradition as well as bricks likely
locally sourced from the Rhine
the plus curl is the best curl but
unfortunately it goes by another name as
well
the will be missed curl currently in
existential danger due to Amsterdam's
government removing it off of its
streets the plus kill is imperfect you
see
foreign
the plus kill with its perfect ratios is
not perfectly optimized for space it
also needs to be routinely cleaned by
Municipal staff due to it not being
directly connected to a water system
and this has caused serious issues with
more selfish residents who would choose
their own hygienic needs over the
interests of the larger City Hall
options
[Music]
foreign
although there have been some moonshot
attempts to introduce handicap and
female friendly plus curls the strong
cast iron frame was not strong enough to
keep the plus cool alive
instead in its ashes emerges a new Dutch
public urinal one that puts all others
to shame this is the eurolift the
quintessential Dutch invention carrying
the netherlands's strongest National
traditions on its cold metal shoulders
the country is known for some of the
most intricate and well-developed Water
Management Systems in the world a
network of intricate dike and Bridge
systems that keeps deadly water at Bay
connected into that water system is the
ai-powered self-rinsing eurolift paying
direct homage to the country's strong
grip on water
and the Netherlands is also known for
its serious investment into world-class
public infrastructure not everyone uses
a public urinal so why should all be
burdened by the urinal use of a few the
Dutch solution as always pragmatic and
based on consensus
build a urinal that during the day is
shy but pops up at night when the demand
is high although some of the eurolift
journals may still be male-centric it
matters less because they're more space
efficient the single pillar borrowing
more from the oldest French pesoir is
designed to have three urinators
simultaneously and the design also
intelligently cuts out of the
cylindrical frame to carefully mask out
self-conscious urinators
it's exactly the type of brilliant
engineering that you would expect from
the country home to companies like asml
the brushed stainless steel frame
communicates seriousness and a respect
for civilians who need to use the urinal
stainless steel is also a significant
upgrade to the cast iron model because
stainless steel is resistant to
corrosion steel also comes off
professional and clean
and the top of the eurolift once not in
use is designed to blend in with the
natural landscape like a chameleon
but the eurolift improves upon
everything
it has multiple models so unlike the
plus curl some iterations of the
eurolift are unisex and also handicap
accessible
okay so I know what some of you guys are
thinking how do you model and animate
the Dutch public urinal that comes out
of the ground
well the answer is actually really
simple blender and a lot of online
videos and courses
you want to learn how to make a video
like this one right now on skillshare
there's already hundreds of videos on
blender
in fact I picked out a few courses that
you can follow so you can learn how to
make this type of 3D video as well
I also highly recommend checking out
Shima Bulgaria's work this guy is a
genius and he just happens to have
multiple underrated skillshare courses
explaining his workflow
also credit where credit is due
skillshare is honestly the only reason I
can make these videos more than a year
ago if I hadn't followed polymatter's
courses on thumbnails you probably
wouldn't be watching this video also if
video editing isn't really your thing
there's of course thousands of other
courses and the best part is that you
can try all these videos without paying
anything because the first 1000 people
to use my link in the pin comment in
description will get a one month free
trial